and is with us in Sacramento hi Ann how
are you I'm great how are you Dave
better than I deserve what's up well I
think my circumstances are kind of quite
a bit different from other people you've
been talking to I was introduced to you
about three months ago I read a couple
of your books I'm 66 years old but I'm
married to a man that is 80 just turned
80 as we've been married about four and
a half years when I retired from my job
I had about 70 thousand dollars in
investments that dropped down to 50 this
was ten years ago it dropped down to 50
and now I'm up to about 82 so I've
invested very conservatively and I
haven't done well in the market at all
I've been with about five different
investment companies and they always
take the cream of the crop off the top
when you get in so they haven't done
well my husband and I have saved about
eleven thousand dollars in investment so
we've got a total of about ninety three
and our incremental income is very good
we've got he's got two retirements I've
got one there's an annuity but we both
get Social Security so our growth income
right here is about one hundred and
seven thousand dollars a little bit more
than that so we don't really need to get
into our investments in fact we haven't
ever since we've been married we just I
haven't we haven't touched him at all
anyway just wonder if you can give me a
little guidance right now in stock in
our investments we've got 36 percent in
domestic eighteen and foreign 36 in
bonds and nine in short-term and I'm
throwing a lot out of you but we also
bought a second home my home was paid
for when we got married so we have a
second home in a more southern weather
that better weather vicinity and it's
worth about two hundred twenty thousand
and we've got it we all about a hundred
and thirty five on it so that's another
question who should rent it out whether
it should sell it should should we enjoy
it as we do how often are you there
I'm sorry how often are you there
not a lot right
during the winter months we try to get
here and then maybe how often are you
there
how often maybe once a month for a week
other than winter months and we're here
about three months okay well that's a
lot that's more than I thought okay
why don't have you thought about just
moving there we have that it's hard to
the families up the other way but that
is an option we have discussed us yeah
okay well I mean that they just they
make hotels at either end and you could
enjoy those for a lot less money but
that's nothing here is killing me
I'm not a big proponent of bonds as you
know from listening to me and I assume
when you talk about the way you've got
this stuff invested that you mean it's
invested in mutual funds yeah okay
that's good news so you're well
diversified among those categories short
term the only thing I do short term for
is for an emergency fund and I don't
know if nine percent $10,000 if that's
your only emergency fund and that's
probably about right no we do have a ten
thousand an emergency fund in a dish in
addition to this okay so really in a
sense that leaves you 20 that's still
not the end of the world and the bonds
is not the in the world you're probably
a little heavier in that than I would
have you that's more of a traditional
portfolio that you the financial
planning community would outline that I
don't agree with but I don't think it's
the end of the world the biggest thing
is you know as interest rates go up
those bond values are going to go down
that's the thing you got to remember
about those and that's my biggest
problem with bonds is that they really
don't give as good a return as stocks
and they have virtually the same level
of volatility and so that that's my my
biggest gripe I'm not a bond fan but
other than that I don't hear anything
there that's done you know poorly or
that I would jump up and down and say oh
it was a bad idea or those kinds of
things it's not necessarily a bad idea
so you know I you know I think you
probably need to stay the course
the court one question you could ask
yourself is just this question you're
asking about the housing and you might
be better off to go completely one
direction or the other and just say you
know one we're with family we're gonna
so we're gonna keep the vacation house
sell the other one
with up they were visiting family we're
just going to you know rent something or
we're gonna just get a hotel you can get
that comparatively the number of dollars
out-of-pocket a lot cheaper than owning
something owning something is pretty
much a luxury in these situations and
you don't have to but that's a way you
could free up a bunch of cash this is
the Dave Ramsey chef
you